[Music]
to an untrained eye you see a rainforest
but someone who has a little bit of
information of what was going on there
you can see the effects of humans all
over the place
[Music]
the mayor lived here for over 1,500
years sustaining densities that were
higher at some point than what we have
today even when you see the forest as
somewhat pristine it shows the Maya hand
right there
[Music]
the word for bat in my a thoughts and
thoughts permeates the whole my universe
my name is Rodrigo Medellin and I'm a
professor at the University of Mexico in
the Institute of ecology but live in
pretty much every ecosystem in the world
they're incredibly diverse everybody
does a different kind of job and you can
see that just by looking at their faces
and their structure of the wings and the
structure of the whole body
46 years ago was when I first had a bat
in my hand for many years I've been
documenting the ecosystem services
provided by bats all over Mexico but in
the back of my mind I had always had
this dream of working with two of the
most spectacular species of bats in the
world these bats are very rare they're
the biggest in this continent they're
the apex predators they are the Jaguars
of the background
[Music]
all we know really was studied in the
60s compared to many other species of
bats that we know about they're
absolutely unknown full of mysteries
[Music]
finding rules is a major major conundrum
for anybody working on bats
the researchers were able to find a
couple of fantastic ruse of false
vampire bats which provides an awesome
opportunity to get some of the first
pictures of these species in their
natural habitat my name is Anand Varma
I'm a photographer for National
Geographic magazine the greater false
vampire bat ruse in these trees and a
cavity inside a hollow tree it's the
first known roost of the species in the
country so I climbed this tree and I put
a camera trap and so that's going to
photograph the bats as they leave their
roost every night when I first got here
I thought wow this is this is gonna be
easy this is straightforward there's a
tree the bats living it's not that far
off the ground got some pictures didn't
quite nail it they're never quite in the
right spot but the triggers working a
bunch of bats leaving
I thought done you know we're gonna get
some amazing images like many things
this project has hit some snags I found
out three days into working on this tree
that I'm allergic to I ended up in the
emergency room with an infected rash
it's like okay first of all we're gonna
need to be a little bit more careful
with that what are you gonna do the
cameras already up there so
so look no bats no bats they're not
there no bats I guess we can try and see
if we can find them there yeah I guess
they must be switching back and forth
and that's one of the big mysteries
about these things we don't know how
reliably they're they using a particular
roost and that's why we want to put some
radios on them to follow them around but
we know that there's this other roost at
least at least a second roof so we have
to find out this is one of the least
known Mayan archaeological sites it
turns out that it's got a couple of
rooms in there and we found a colony of
a bat that is really rare it is
threatened under the Mexican legislation
and it's one of the first species to
disappear once you disturb the
rainforest
Walli falls vampire roast there are
really powerful animals carnivorous bats
Wow seeing those bats happening into
them is an incredible experience very
little has been done to study these bats
either in captivity or in the wild and
so we're just getting started at trying
to see what we can do to document these
animals and what we can do to understand
these animals what I was really excited
about with this project is the prospect
of being able to lend my expertise in
photography to help the researcher that
Rodrigo is doing here in Mexico
I've brought a number of infrared
cameras and triggers and that's going to
help us photograph them in the wild in
their natural habitat without disturbing
them as well as trying to capture some
of their behavior and some of their
movement
[Music]
[Music]
the species is incredible they live in
these family groups and so it's really
cool to be able to come here and try to
help understand the basic biology of
these creatures that are incredibly
charismatic and we just don't know very
much about them
[Music]
bats tend to get kind of a bad
reputation there's these kind of almost
mythical creatures that you can hear as
a whoosh by you at night but you can
rarely see them what I want to do with
my photography is do justice to these
mysterious creatures of the night
[Music]
[Music]
this is why I'm a photographer be able
to come to a new place in the world see
incredible species in its natural
environment even though it's secreting
this you know toxic resin to be able to
climb this thing and then to be able to
review pictures and see how they're
moving through the night I mean typical
wing is coming out like that that seems
that one seems to have taken off above
further than the other it just feels
like the cutting edge of this
exploration of the species of the
natural history and be able to
contribute something to the research of
these animals that's an incredibly
rewarding aspect of this work they're
all grooming they spent a long time that
would be an amazing picture all they're
all heads in different angles wings and
different angles this is the best time
to be studying these paths we have the
technology we have the people we have
the population to me studying these two
BOTS
is a keystone to understanding the whole
bat universe in a mile
[Music]
you
[Music]